[Musik]
die vfg die sagt ja sie knüpft sich
jetzt das klima thema vor weil alle
anderen geräte hinterherlaufen ist der
klimaschutz alternativlos es geht nicht
um kritik geht um physikalische
biologische chemische wahrheiten und
klar ist wir müssen den co2 methan
lachgas und andere treibhausgase in der
emissionsmenge verringern weltweit
das sind die größten emittenten
gefordert china indien die usa
da sind wir mit unserer technologie
gefordert das heißt ich rate uns vor
alleingängen er habe ich gerade uns in
investitionen für technologien zu gehen
und denn damit im grunde genommen der
welt zeigen wie man emissionen
verringern kann ohne überall verzicht
üben wie findet ihr sohn eigentlich
kreta ja nimmt sie nicht so wichtig wie
die medien
ich fühle mich in der meinungsbildung zu
greta nicht beteiligen
die einen himmelt sie einen die anderen
verteilen das überdrehen völlig
übertrieben
[Musik]